ضريبه الخروج انا عايزه بس اوضح لان يمكن
كتير مش مش واضحه لهم النقطه دي كان في
ضريبه على الخروج من مصر بقيمه 50 جنيه اي
ما يعادل دولار ونص فاللي حصل الضريبه
الجديده اللي بيتم النهارده التصويت عليها
في البرلمان هي زيادتها ل 100 جنيه يعني
لثلاثه دولار وشويه تقريبا همم فهو ده هي
زياده في الضريبه بقيمه تقريبا دولار ونصف
يستثنى من ذلك الاجانب اللي جايين فقط
للسياحه في الخمس مدن السياحيه اللي هي
جنوب سيناء والبحر الاحمر والاقصر واسوان
ومرسى مطروح
هذه الضريبه يعني اثارت جدل على السوشيال
ميديا في الايام الاخيره يعني في طبعا له
ان دلوقتي مع ارتفاع سعر الدولار ومع
التضخم
ضريبه زي دي ممكن تبقى يعني
عيب اضافي وفي بعض الاخر قال لا ده عادي
احنا ليه بنتقبل هذه الضرائب من دول اخرى
ومن شركات اخرى
ويعني وبنرفض ان احنا ندفعها هنا الدولار
ونص زياده لا يمثل الكثير بالنسبه
للمسافر وطبعا ده بتضاف على تذكره الطيران
طيب انا انا في حد الجدل كمان اتفضلي
لان هي جه القرار ده مع قرارات اخرى
بزياده بعض الضرائب الاخرى على السلع اللي
هي الغير اساسيه يعني زي المسارح برده
بيتم التصويت عليها طيب بس في حد بيقول لي
ايضا انه انه سمر باشات عندها كل الاسرار
وخاصه اسرار سقاره لسه ما اتحكتش ايه
الموضوع
سقاره دي بتاعتنا احنا كنا بنتابع حفريات
او بعثات سقاره بقى لنا اكتر من يعني
البعثه دي بدات تشتغل اللي اكتشفت اللي
عملت على هذا الكشف بالامس بدات تشتغل في
هذه المنطقه منذ 2018 واحنا كنا
بكاميراتنا معاهم في كل كشف جديد الكشف
الجديد هو في منطقه اسمها جبانه
البوبصطيون جبانه الباباسيون دي جبانه او
مجموعه مقابر للحيوانات المقدسه
لقوا فيها على مدار السنين اللي فاتت
مجموعه كبيره من التوابيت الملونه
والحيوانات المقدسه اللي كانوا قدماء
المصريين بيحنطوها وامبارح تم الاعلان عن
الكشف عن اكبر ورشتين للتحميط في هذه
المنطقه في سقاره فيها الورشتين فيهم كل
ادوات التحنيط الاسره والادوات اللي كانت
بتستخدم في عمليه التح سواء للبني ادمين
او للحيوانات كما تم ايضا الكشف عن
مقبرتين
لناس من كبار الكهنه وكبار الموظفين واحده
من الدوله القديمه تقريبا من 4400 سنه
والثانيه من الدوله الحديثه تقريبا 3400
سنه
يا اسرار جديده راح اكون معاك اول باول
شكرا
لزميلتنا سمر باشا يعطيك العافيه
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات